probably the coolest thing to come out
of the genetic results is how small the
human population probably was if you go
back to around 70 to 80 thousand years
ago we were very nearly extinct probably
the the total number of people living in
the world at that time and again we were
still all living in Africa could have
fit into a small symphony hall around
2,000 people maybe even less and so we
nearly went extinct and this was
probably due to climate shifts that were
occurring around that time we were in
the midst of the last ice age things
really started to get bad between
seventy and eighty thousand years ago
there was a massive volcanic eruption in
Sumatra known as Mount Toba that erupted
around 74,000 years ago the combination
of these factors probably drove the
human population very close to
extinction and we came back from that
and we figured out a way to survive
these horrible climatic conditions and
that probably primed the pump if you
will to allow us to go out and explore
the rest of the world and actually make
proper forays into the part of Asia
often to europe southeast asia australia
and ultimately into the americas between
fifteen and twenty thousand years ago so
the evidence is that we started to leave
between 50 and 60 thousand years ago
following a coastal route along the
south coast of asia beachcombing our way
along living on you know marine
resources shellfish probably doing a
little bit of fish trapping we rapidly
made it down to southeast asia to
australia by run fifty thousand years
ago when humans show up in the fossil
record there there was a later migration
between 45 and 50 thousand years ago
according to our data that came via an
inland route cross the Sahara at a point
when the Sahara was actually a very nice
place to live every 20,000 years or so
due to fluctuations the way the earth
precesses in its orbit the way it
rotates and this causes shifts in the
way the monsoon rains fall in Africa
every 20,000 years or so the Sahara is
actually a pretty nice place and it was
an extension of the grasslands of East
Africa around 50,000 years ago and this
allowed people to slowly move up into
northern Africa out into the middle east
and that led them on their way to the
rest of the world so it's it's really
kind of these these grand sweeping
Paleolithic migratory routes that we're
following but also
very specific details I mean all the way
up to the present day nearly historical
events we published a paper about a
month ago in the American Journal of
Human Genetics showing that the
Christian population of Lebanon is
carrying genetic markers that tied them
to the Crusaders from Western Europe who
can / only about 800 900 years ago and
so these are events that we knew about
from the historical record hadn't seen a
genetic trail prior to this because we
didn't have enough samples but now we're
seeing it you know as we increase the
sample size everything from the very
earliest days of our species up to very
recent events what underpins the work
we're doing a scientific work is the
idea that DNA changes over time at a
regular rate so DNA is a very long
linear molecule it's a coded molecule
therefore subunits so think of it as
Morse code but with four different
possibilities rather than just dots and
dashes and it's the sequence of these
subunits that is basically a blueprint
to make another version of you and if
you choose deaf kids as your parents did
you have to copy this very long molecule
or document to pass it on to them and
when you're copying it because it is so
very long there are billions of these
subunits occasionally you're going to
make a mistake a typo so imagine copying
the longest text you can think of war
and peace but multiply it by 100 and
you're copying it by hand staying up
late at night and you're very very
careful but occasionally you're going to
make a type out substitute an eye for an
e or in the case of DNA SC for a G or an
A for a tea these don't happen very
often at the genetic level they're
called mutations when they do occur and
they occur at a rate of around 50 per
genome per generation so not very often
50 out of the billions of subunits we
have but when they happen and they get
passed on through the generations
they've become markers of descent and
that's how we place people into these
lineages so again if you share one of
these markers with someone you share an
ancestor the person first have that
change in their DNA now because we know
the rate at which they occur by looking
at the number of changes that have
accumulated on a lineage we can estimate
the age of that lineage and by comparing
the distribution of the lineage two
populations all over the world seeing
which populations it's found in in which
population which populations it's not
found in indigenous groups people
lived in the same place for a long
period of time give us an insight into
their ancestors genetic patterns by
looking at the distribution in those
groups all over the world we can
actually map where it originated and how
it spread around the planet